called feminism guys honest citizens
honest citizen polygamy meant men in
power took women away from average men
by force and other men were forced to be
a you
eunich you know they've been uh
polygamy was not
not a choice women were forced due to
finance women were seen as property
chris mccarthy thank you for the super
chat lawrence bullock do they have
common law marriage in the uk i don't
actually know i don't know what's
common-law marriage it's when you live
with someone overseas that's what i
thought okay yeah do you have that here
i think we do things have slightly
changed i've heard recently but so yeah
there used to be a thing if you cohabit
for a certain amount of time she is
entitled to uh
your you know
like your wife the the household essence
yeah it's still difficult
yeah it's still it's still it's still
harder hard to get even without marriage
yeah that's crazy daniel um
i'm saying
they're like they're like twisting men's
arms you will be married
you will
daniel marriage has always favored women
um mar i can't read your name when is
the pearly
waifu pillow gonna drop what does that
mean what's a waifu pillow i don't know
what that is
oh i think it's those um because in
japan they have these long pillows where
men can you know single people can just
hug them as they and your pictures on it
come on major merch
okay can women lay off the we're hormone
hormonal so our emotions change all the
time so that doesn't make us accountable
it's a title excuse your hormones change
you're not on math
87 a man was shot and killed by police
after his son called the cops after
seeing that his mother stabbed his
father the father who had a disability
had reportedly called the police over
the abuse prior
lawrence bullock
women that proudly say they will not
settle is a big red flag because the
fairy tale man they are always looking
for doesn't exist and they're never
satisfied michael federer 100 super chat
let's go
um
this is a cute conversation but the time
has passed for u.s and western women we
are going overseas and sisters it may
take three generations to get it back
we wealthy fit older men don't want you
and we have foreign women now well lucky
for you i am overseas
okay matt butcher bottom line is if you
marry and have kids or and or have kids
with a lady it's a gamble you never know
what you'll get despite the red flag
despite red flags the odds are against
you
um
let me just refresh it real quick guys
like the video come on like a like is
free how many people we got in here two
thousand
oh we got a thousand likes you guys did
come through last time i just exposed
myself depending who watched this video
so like the video please
like the video
who's watching
i thought i thought you were single
what's going on i am single okay okay
that is what people are watching
[Laughter]
um okay why do you think that
men
are why do you think that men are
expected to deal with women's hormones
but women like us being hormonal every
month but women aren't expected to deal
with men's hormones that they're horny
who said that women don't deal with
men's hormone and horny moments well
technically yeah you'll be dealing with
that yeah yeah you still be dealing with
it do you feel like
do you feel like it's the same guys
no
no
not for the most part
men
men have to endure i'm washing my hair i
have a headache and and all of that
whilst if if
you know and the guy can't really say
look
it's that time of night for me
i need to have this whilst if a woman
just basically goes crazy and
loses her collective [ __ ] every month
men have to kind of grind their teeth
nowadays they can't even say are you on
your period that is going to trigger
more [ __ ] coming your way just by saying
is it that time of the month love i just
need to know
thanks you have to download the app
yourself just so you know
you know there's no question you sync
the flow out together
i don't know i think women go through a
lot of biological you know
imbalances throughout the month and
a man would be happy to just yeah if
she's in her mood and her you know i
mean he'll run tesco get her whatever
she wants and do whatever but if you say
to the woman yo i'm feeling a bit come
get on your knees and it's bit
nah i got other things i want to do and
that's to say i don't know i don't know
i think because men you
it's in you okay
i don't know i think men
it's easier for men to be horny
it's because they're women but it's
because of our health yeah like it's our
hormones it's our hormones the basic
question is or hormones the base
question is about hormones like women
men are willing to accept women's
hormones and the way they are at the end
of the month when it comes to a man's
hormones a woman's a bit like now in the
mood
like even on the couch what i said would
you accept a guy cheating like they're
just they're horny it's just from time
to time you might [ __ ] a hoe
yeah can i connect can i ask you can ask
a question right okay
so the primary hormone right for sexual
arousal is testosterone
right do you know how much testosterone
the woman produces you can check this as
well
no it's i think it's like anywhere
between 50 to 100 nanograms do you know
how much men produce
it's up to a thousand
yeah exactly what i'm saying so you know
how horny you get
times that by 20. that's what i'm saying
men are who are more than women
exactly but dealing but you dealing with
his hormones
would be like well when he's horny
can he have sex with you or anyone else
that should do this okay okay do you see
what i'm saying
okay
but because when a woman has a period
meant to have the luxury of saying i'm
just going to go out for a few days i'm
just going to i'm going to s out for
like two three days
do your thing and then you know
[Laughter]
like i mean i think women well i don't
know from my experience i'm more horny
when i'm on my people yeah you know when
they're coming up too men genuinely
don't want to have this woman on their
period
unless unless your name is dracula and
most people don't believe it i don't
want to know this
you're very quiet
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i already asked the question
you agreed